MEGHAN MEHTA: Android
Q Beta 3 is here.
This version has several new
updates, including dark theme
and gesture navigation.
Let's dive in.
Beta 3 adds a system setting
to switch apps on a device
to use a dark theme.
Having a dark theme
isn't just aesthetic.
On some devices, it can
extend battery life.
Therefore, when users switch
to Battery Saver mode,
the dark theme
will automatically
be used on Pixel and
selected OEM devices.
To customize your
app's dark theme,
extend your app theme from
theme.AppCompat.DayNight,
or MaterialComponents.
From there, you
enable the feature
by calling AppCompatDelegat
e.setDefaultNightMode.
The recommended values for this
are Light Night No, Dark Night
Yes, Use System Default,
Night Follow System.
Keep in mind that
the past in value
is not persisted, so you
need to set it each time
your app becomes visible.
You will also need to
update your themes, styles,
and layouts so that
users can seamlessly
switch between your app's
light and dark themes.
Using material design components
makes this especially easy
because its color theme
system provides easy access
to well-defined colors.
Android Q also introduces
gestural navigation,
allowing you to
perform sliding motions
to both navigate back one screen
and return to the home screen.
Gestural navigation provides
a system-wide, edge-to-edge
experience.
This means your apps can use
more of the device's screen.
On Beta 3, a swipe up
shows the home screen,
and a horizontal edge swipe
will now take you back
to the previous app.
If your app relies
on similar gestures,
users may accidentally
trigger the system gestures
and alter the intended
experience of your app.
For example, a horizontal
edge swipe by default
takes you back to
the previous app.
If you encounter this
sort of conflict,
use gesture exclusion rectangles
to override system gestures
within particular areas
along device edges.
When users perform a gesture
inside of these rectangles,
the gesture will
trigger an action
in your app instead of
the typical system action.
Although gesture exclusion
rectangles give you
flexibility in updating
your app's experience,
you should keep the following
best practices in mind.
Avoid vertical swipes
near the system
navigation elements because
this gesture will always
be a way for users
to exit the app.
We also don't recommend creating
a gesture exclusion zone that
covers the entire edge of
the screen, which the system
recognizes as a back action.
To enhance user privacy, Android
has created a sandbox view
of external storage that
apps targeting Android Q use
by default. Your app
can access the files
that it creates on
external storage.
But access to other apps' files
through runtime permissions
is limited to
common media types,
such as photos and music.
To access other
files, your app can
request that the user
give permission to access
a particular file or directory
by using either the Action Open
Document or Action Open
Document Tree intent.
To help you respond to
your context questions
more efficiently, Android
Q introduces Smart Actions.
Smart Actions can now
automatically suggest actions
and responses to conversations.
For example, in
this notification
the system suggests
reply to the message.
And since the message
contains an address,
it includes a button to
navigate to that address.
This system provides
several suggestions for you
so you don't need to implement
this functionality from scratch
in your app.
You can analyze a
list of messages
to see if there are
any actions associated
with it using this Adjust
Conversation Actions API.
Pass in conversation
text, and the API
will provide a list of
suggestions corresponding
to possible actions.
It will also generate a
list of possible replies.
But, for now, this reply feature
is only supported in English.
We've also added an
ability to detect languages
in a piece of text.
Developers can use the Detect
Language feature of the text
classifier class to pass in text
and see what language it is in.
Enough of me talking.
Go try it for yourself.
Follow the link
in the description
to install Android Q Beta,
which is now available on more
than 15 devices.
Release notes and
support resources
can be found on the Android
Q Beta developer site.
Let us know how you like Android
Q by leaving us feedback.
Your feedback is important
to us in building
a platform for everyone.
Happy coding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]